it's hard to remember that there was a
time when most people didn't know the
meaning of
wakanda forever but few anticipated that
chadwick boseman's regal performance
would help to make a massive hit of
black panther
turns out the real-life man was just as
interesting as the king he portrayed
chadwick boseman who became one of the
brightest stars of marvel's cinematic
universe
was an actor as believable in high
octane action scenes
as he was depicting the solemn duties of
a nation's leader
while the character had been around for
decades it was bozeman's legendary
performance as the king of wakanda that
made black panther a household name
and so it was a brutal shock to the
world when news hit of his unexpected
passing at the age of 43.
according to a statement released by his
family bozeman died after a brave
four-year fight with colon cancer by far
his best-known movie as a lead actor
black panther changed the world when it
premiered in 2018
with great reviews award nominations and
over a billion dollars at the box office
the movie took superhero cinema to
adventurous new heights
within weeks of the movie's premiere
bozeman went from being a lesser known
character actor
to a bona fide worldwide cultural icon
but black panther wasn't bozeman's first
time playing a world-changing hero
before he stepped into t'challa's royal
sandals he was depicting the all-time
greats of music
sports and lawmaking bozeman's first
starring role came in 2013
when he portrayed the legendary jackie
robinson in the baseball biopic
42 he followed this up a year later with
another biography
get on up in which he brought the
electric skill of singer james brown to
life
three years later he once again slipped
effortlessly into an iconic figure's
skin
when he played lawyer and later supreme
court justice thurgood marshall
in 2017's marshall though some of his
marvel cinematic universe co-stars might
have had longer careers than bozeman
before they joined the sprawling
franchise no one
had more experience playing real-life
heroes it might be surprising to learn
that bozeman
actually spent much of his life wanting
to be behind the camera
instead of in front of it his original
aspirations didn't even involve the
camera at all
only a pen some paper and his own
imagination
bozeman began his life in the performing
arts as a playwright
writing and staging his first play in
high school entitled
crossroads the play was a deeply
personal piece
the story of a basketball teammate who'd
been shot and killed while they were
still in school
the actor recalled his inspiration to
write the story during an interview with
rolling stone in 2018
saying i just had a feeling that this
was something that was calling me
suddenly playing basketball wasn't as
important
years later his play deep azure would go
on to be performed by professional
theater companies and even win a few
awards
writing wasn't the only experience
bozeman had on the creative side of the
performing arts
he also nurtured an ambition in being a
director and originally began to study
acting as a means of achieving that goal
his college degree was a testament to
this ambition
he graduated from howard university in
2000 with the bachelors of fine arts in
directing
bozeman remarked in a radio interview
with new york's power 105.1 in 2014
i actually started out wanting to direct
wanting to write
i only started acting because i wanted
to know what actors were
doing how to communicate with the actors
and then i realized i'm supposed to do
all of it
bozeman went on to study the craft from
every angle possible
including a stint at the world famous
oxford university
and while bozeman's acting talents were
a delight for audiences
everywhere to enjoy we can only imagine
what the world might have lost with his
life cut
short before he could write and direct
once again connections are key in any
industry
and can be a tremendously positive force
in providing for an actor's big break
how can anyone let alone someone
pursuing the arts navigate such stormy
seas alone
bozeman had a few mentors but veteran
actor felicia rashad stands out as a
particularly meaningful one
rashad has a massive treasure trove of
experience to share
from her starring role as claire
huxtable in the cosby show
to her tony winning performance in a
raisin in the sun
rashad is a grand dame and an
accomplished teacher
rashad and bozeman met at howard where
she served as one of his professors as
bozeman later recalled to rolling stone
quote
we were just trying to aspire to her
excellence all these years later
it seems clear that he made that goal a
reality felicia rashad might rank as one
of bozeman's most impressive mentors but
she's far from the only one
it turns out that oscar winner box
office breaker and general hollywood
icon denzel
washington also had a hand in bozeman's
success when he helped fund bozeman's
time at a prestigious summer theater
program
in britain's legendary oxford university
after bozeman and a number of other
students got into the program but found
they wouldn't be able to afford it
rashad reached out to some celebrity
friends for support bozeman discovered
after the fact that washington had
funded him and wrote him a thank you
letter
though he was reluctant to reach out to
him for fear that washington might think
he was asking for extra help
bozeman ended up getting to thank
washington in person at the new york
premiere of black panther
he was like well i haven't met you yet
and i said yeah i got to tell you
something you know you um pay for me to
go to school he said
oh oh so that's why i'm here you owe me
money
teaching is one of the most everyday
acts of heroism around
bozeman himself had participated in this
long and noble tradition working
naturally in the world of drama back in
2014
the michigan chronicle profiled bozeman
as a star on the rise
paying special attention to his tenure
at the schomburg center for research in
black culture in harlem
there he worked as a drama instructor as
part of the schomburg junior scholars
program
and continued to highlight its important
work in his new capacity as a world
famous movie star
any career path can be a rocky road but
few are more harrowing than that of an
actor
one great audition can change a life
completely but so many aspiring talents
never get their big break bozeman knows
this better than most
before he was cast as jackie robinson in
42
he was thinking of giving up on acting
altogether he told gq in 2014
nobody had called me nobody told me
anything i had gone in for it 100
but there was no reason for me to think
i'd done well
he came perilously close to giving up on
acting altogether
until he landed the role of robinson and
skies began to clear
given that this interview happened
before he was cast in what would become
his biggest role by far
even he didn't realize how much higher
he was going to climb
stars come from all sorts of backgrounds
some draw from childhoods rich in love
but poor in finances
other come from long and glamorous lines
of hollywood hitmakers
and some like boseman came from loving
homes and families that cheer them on
through thick and thin
and his was a big family with his
extended family accounted for
his number of blood relatives ends up
less like a cheering section
and more like the entirety of the
bleachers he shared in an interview with
the mr porter journal in 2016.
when my grandmother died she left 115
grandkids and great grandkids
that was just one side he credited his
family's love and support
as key to his ascension to stardom and
one can bet they must be proud of how
gloriously far he'd gotten in his career
in life
he leaves behind a legacy that will be
remembered not just by his family
but the entire world